so today I'm going to talk about a
mycotoxins and how to use two different
methods to calculate how much mycotoxins
in your food one method is called a
stable isotope dilution Si and the other
is called a matrix match the calibration
method and into this pretend
presentation I'm going to cover the
following aspects first I will briefly
introduce the background of mycotoxins
and how to use simple preparation to do
the to to your sample then how to do the
detection with LC ms/ms method here our
introduces some of the challenges faced
by LC ms/ms and also explain what is
Stata
what is matrix match the calibration
what is the Pro and accounts for each
method then I will show you some of the
results are obtained from commercialized
food matrices and also using two
different methods comparison then comes
the conclusion and acknowledgments so
first what our mycotoxins the roller can
have a pretty good guess from the name
toxins means poisons micro indicates
that they derived from fungus or mold so
they are actually the secondary
metabolites released from mold or fungus
so what do they do they actually be
activated your immune system put your
immune system into sleep in that case
they will generate a lot of health
problems such as a fatigue joint pain
the skin rashes or immune suppression or
even cancer so what are the causes most
of the time they come from the food
you're eating mainly found in corn
grains beans coffee vegetables or fruits
and meats so you would think about all
the processed food we're eating most of
them have some type of corn especially
loves GMO corn so 90%
I'm guessing you're having mycotoxins
if you're drinking beer probably you
will get mycotoxins too because those
bad greens like a people even don't want
them to feed animals lay and they'll be
using them to ferment eight the beer so
since the we all great data drinking
alcohol is not healthy anyway but who
ever thought you about the drinking
coffee could be so dangerous - right so
you know the coffee business is
different like Chow the dried and
processed or stored the mold can grow
and micro toxins can be created right so
there is a special micro toxin called or
core toxin a it's very toxic - keenie
and it's a carcinogen it is present in
specially in coffee so overall when we
for not micro toxins out there it's in
your life your blood and your diet
well after I learn about old mycotoxins
I always ask myself clearly am i eating
mycotoxins or my food full of toxins so
before I Drive myself too crazy I
decided to do some tests that are most
commercially available food matrices so
I heard that the core or maze layer
considered to be the most complex matrix
with the severe contamination of
mycotoxins are just about two types of
corns together with brown rice and the
peanut powder from grocery stores
actually so in order to prove that the
method that I would develop is a curated
owls about the to reference material
from fibers company so I really will
work as science detectives and asking my
questions like a detective you know what
possible types of mycotoxins it will be
there and at what concentration Alice
concentrations safe and how do we do the
detection
so like we lost questions bear in mind I
first have found the 12 most regulated
micro toxins from literature and from
published the work here at the chemical
structures of lost child for chemicals
as we can see they are all small
molecules polar chemical stable and also
layer temperature resistant clearly
while a lot of the countries or most of
the countries they have a very stringent
regulations all those compounds
obviously for obvious reasons right so
regulation levels live vary from country
to country like agency to agency but all
probably at a level of ppb level so
that's equivalent like a teaspoon of
sugar pouring into an Olympic sized
swimming pool so they probably say oh
okay that little amount yes I'm sure
even that little amount of mycotoxin can
make you sick so that means you
definitely don't want lows compounds in
your food so next year we probably will
do a further in depth analysis let's
start with the sample prep so in this
study we used a quick dilute future and
the shoot method according to dr.
Cotton's publication it could be a
universal method you know that means you
can apply this method to multi class
mycotoxins
in different matrices and also like you
can see from the flowchart it's very
easy and straightforward first you just
the way out one gram of your homogenized
the commodity and add to meal of water
to soak the dry powder for two minutes
or even more than you sparking or
targeted mycotoxins at this step for QC
samples and then if you're using stable
isotope dilution I see you can add your
standard internal standard here and you
can just use this
of extraction solvent for the extraction
which is half acetyl natural and half
water vertex in the centrifuge then
transfer the top layer or supernatant to
the filter in here we use something
slightly different from kitronik paper
we use the Thompson single data filter
vial including the syringe buyer in this
case it's easy and save you type well
just in case you're now familiar with
this Thompson vial again briefly like
explain how it works
it contains the mainly two parts the
bottom shell and the top plunger with
the filter unit first you just transfer
your top layer or the stupid supernatant
to the bottom shell then you just insert
your plunger with the future into the
shell half way down at this tab you can
either vortex shake or just a necessary
and then you just depress down the top
wonder all the way down to the bottom of
your shell in this case you filtered
your example so as you can see the vial
is really small so it to greatly reduce
the loss of your sample compared to the
strange filter and it only consumes like
up to 500 microliters of your sample and
this is also the final file trick to to
your mess back
underdone wait the follow-up the LCMS
method for mycotoxins by using the
Raptor biphenyl column as you can see
from the Camaro Graham like older 12
micro toxins were resolved or analyzed
it only happened five and a half minutes
so as you can see including two isobars
Phil Morrison b2 and a few moments in b3
they are fully resolved or compulsively
and also the back pressure is relatively
low is less than 4000 psi in that case
you don't need to worry about using a
you HPLC or something so for further
information or details that you can
refer our publication it's an open
access so you probably will asking me
like what is the success or what is the
secret of your success so I can share
with you the secret is this buffer so as
you notice that I added a two million
more ammonium formate buffer in both
mobile phase a and a B why is that I can
show your comparison in that case you
will understand it you will understand
why so this is one of the examples that
I did for tuning as you can see this is
without buffer when I was doing the
tuning for aflatoxin v2 the sodium I dr.
is the majority ion or the predominant
Alya when I was doing the tuning I
barely can see the M + H so after an
audit of my buffer even with little
amount only 2 million more ammonium for
me but for the situation to which the
completely so it greatly reduce the
sodium adaptor I should remind you that
for most of the mycotoxin is the case
and except for h t2 t2
whew - and b1 b2 b3 and orchid toxins or
Co toxin a there is no big difference
between buffer and no buffer I mean like
if you are experienced if you are
experiencing the same situation where
you are having problems in seeing your
parent ìiíll
you probably can try this method they
also has like reported in other
literature's too so like so far been
talking about
lc-ms method and actually there are also
many other analytical methods have been
developed for mycotoxin analysis such as
the GCMs SS the TLC immunoassays and the
salon but increasingly LCMS is more and
more popular I think it's more suitable
for this type of analysis is compared to
UV or fluorescence detectors ms allows
the analysis or identification without
any derivatives Asian in addition mass
spec also offers better sensitivity
throughput specificity and efficiency
however there is one challenge that
faced by the lc/ms technique calcified
electrospray ionisation okay you
probably will ask okay what is the
matrix effect simple way I can explain
it in this way matrix effect is caused
divided junk from your matrix that
collude with your target analyte because
the problem of lighting enhancement or
suppression of your target ionization
signals
resulting in loss of precision and
accuracy to have any like ways to solve
this problem well we do in general I
categorize them into three different
groups first or we can do some sample
to remove those junk Romeo target
analyzed as much as possible but there
are some problems so for this method one
thing is
ah there is no measure can see for all
purpose you probably can only target on
what analyzer in one specific I know
light you want specific matrix so in
that case is an outer legacy for all
purpose for multi class method the
second method you can try is to develop
a careful control Rafi to separate the
loss trunk from your target analyte but
this method is kind of you're working in
the dark you have no idea about what is
junks are or what the interference are
what the em arm transitions orders
servants and the third master is more
Universal it's kind of like a not
removing them from your target analyte
it just uses some type of calibration
methods to compensate the interference
or matrix' factors including like stable
isotope dilution I say in short is
called styler and matrix match the
calibration also standard editions then
their addition can be laborious and also
cause a lot of time so in today's
presentation I will mainly focus on
spider and a matrix match but overall I
think there is always a trade-off
among all different methods so like it
really needs you to think about what you
really need to tailor your method in
practice
and first let me explain what is tie-dye
tie-dye stands for stable isotope
dilution si and I can explain it in a
very simple way so here this picture
shows a gradient color of the solution
so I can use it to represent a
calibration curve with like a different
concentrations of my target analytes
as you can see I also sparked my
internal standard the same amount into
those calibration curves well here I'd
like to remind you that this is the
calibration curve that I prepared in the
new solution or solve it
not in any type of the matrix in this
case I build my calibration curves
with the relative response of analyte
and the internal standard so then after
I have my calibration curve I can do i
unknown so those unknowns theoretical a
can be anything it can be like
vegetables or powder of your like coffee
or like a fruits yeah it can be
everything as long as you spiked the
same amount of the internal standards
prior to your extraction so in doing so
it is able to account for both the
extraction and ionization efficiency
however the tricky thing is this
internal standard can be special and
usually it's stable labeled as a topic
internal standard and matching to your
target analyte so I will talk about you
like this more in the following slides
and what is a matrix match the
calibration our first you will have your
unknown samples that you don't have to
use your corresponding general standard
and you will extract your calibration
curve like a using a blank matrix after
extraction you will spike in your target
analyzes into the calibration curve in
this case you will use your calibration
curve to back calculate to your unknowns
in the matrix however before you do the
extraction or do the official-like
studies you have to make sure your
absolute extraction recovery is ranging
from 70 to 120 I'm sorry so you have to
make sure the extraction recovery is
ranging from 70 to 120 indicated in this
case we ignore the loss during
extraction considering that 100 percent
recovery and it could be laborious
honestly here's the think about it if
you are doing Apple you have to prepare
the calibration curve in Apple then you
have to do pear then you have to do
coffee that means you have to prepare
every single calibration curve for each
matrix
you
and while I'm always now to do that to
making decisions so styler versus a
matrix match which method shall I use
this sensor a very hard question to me
actually so it is a very obvious Federer
has a lot of advantages such as a local
function of your sample and it's the
matrix in independent you can just
regenerated one calibration and apply to
all different matrices faster and the
easy obviously and also for loves you
incurred analyte and matrices for
example it's very hard to find a clean
matrix without any mycotoxin in this
case you are not able to use the matrix
match to calculate how much in the food
how much mycotoxins in your food so seta
will be perfect for this situation well
as i mentioned the two internal standard
can be tricky because most of the time
like it might not be available for your
target analyte and even you can buy it
is still very expensive so as far as the
matrix match the method considered
it can eliminate the custom or usage
alpha standard and is also minimize the
matrix effect in a certain way
well as I mentioned to it can be tedious
and the more time-consuming even you
save the cost per internal standard I
think Liberty is another big cost and
the time consuming to so for Low's like
already contaminated always your
mycotoxins or target analyzed it's a
very accurate to do the concentration
calculation and usually I mean like a
matrix effect is invisible it's a hard
to see by eyes it's just just the
reflected by the enhancement or
suppression of your target signals here
I found like a more visible example for
you this canal gram has two parts the
top one is the HT - sparking into the
peanut powder and the bottom one is just
the applying peanut matrix as you can
see the blank it also has the primary
I'm armed transition for HT - which is
the four four seven twenty three to two
eighty five point three I it seems like
an interference present in the blank
matrix so in this case we were not able
to do the integration or calculation
according to this like a primary
quantity quantitation quantifier so
therefore we selected a qualifier which
is less abundant unarmed transition for
four seven point two three two three
forty five point three to do the
quantification and the calculation well
as a result as I mentioned that it's
much less abundant it so I bomb to my ll
o pew from five to ten nanogram per gram
and this only happens to the HT two in
the specific a peanut powder
as it there must be some Co extracted
and the co allude to the junk with this
HP to
okay so here are the matrix to match the
calibration results and a calibration
curve with 100 times the dynamic arrange
or speed and excellent linearity words
observed with this method so the
recovery and the precision of this
method were assessed using two QC
samples 100 and 200 or the top like
analytes such as the oxy polymer films B
1 HT 2 with compounds and the 10 times
lower for aflatoxin and orca toxin a as
you can see the majority of recovery
range from 70 to 120 yeah I'd like to
mention one thing here is that this is
the true recovery or absolute to
recovery showing here because the QC
samples 100 200 those two QC samples
respective before extraction under
compared to the calibration curve which
mycotoxins respect after extraction the
ideal way I think while this method can
compensate the matrix interference
however realistically matrix match can
now to fully account for the different
degrees of the matrix e factors here is
the wine sample as you can see the ran
numbers for the low recovery of
aflatoxin b1 in brown rice as you can
see it's super low in 20s so you may
probably say okay maybe because of the
extraction method suitable for this
alpha toxin b1 but look at the same
compound in other matrices this look
like a layer Oh doing good but maybe
this is another good method of for this
brown rice but look at other compounds
in brown rice they are all at a very
like good numbers 90 to 120 something
like that
so what was the problem I think that's
the matrix effect that's the signal that
got surprised by the Cohen do theta
matrix interference and only affect
either the aflatoxin b1 in particularly
brown rice
well let's take a look at the site of a
substance like it's excellent to result
and across all the four matrices look at
the dynamic range it's the one thousand
times and our square always more than
three nice and the accuracy of above
ninety percent mostly however something
didn't look right
I know I know you will ask me this
question I have trouble for mycotoxins
but why I only show six of them well I
have to be honest with you because when
I first started this work I would like
to save some money so I didn't purchase
all the stable label the internal
standards for all the trials and
mycotoxins so in the hope that I can
share some of the internal standards I
only bought those six internal standards
but turns out it is not good it is
really bad decision and also I was
thinking maybe I can share the internal
standard for other compounds that turn
out that sharing is not always a good
thing
I can explain why so like just I said
how do you know the method you developed
is a good method you have to do like a
fantastic using your reference material
before that I also use the Seidel method
to do the in Curtis sample in Kurt
mycotoxins analysis because I only have
two specs internal standards so I only
calculating the low sixes in corn peanut
powder and a brown rice as you can see
since like the numbers okay except the
oxy me fella know slightly high but I
think overall is the under regulation
I should say like a thank you Asylum and
third otherwise that I couldn't do this
analysis using matrix match and now we
are doing some reference material all
about two different my like about two
different types of reference materials
are from feathers and the lace factor
for different micro toxins in it as you
can see the oxy Novella no aflatoxin b1
orca toxin a and the zero element so the
middle column measured value is the like
remembered that i obtained from my
method and the second column to the
right that's assigned the value offer
the bias levels so as you can see the
accuracies of for most of the compounds
are all above ninety one percent which
is perfect right it's very accurate
rating except a1 compound
why is that because i said i said i
didn't buy the internal standard for
this compound digest they use a closed
layered lutein aflatoxin g one internal
standard as the analog and to see if it
could serve as a substitute the internal
standard but still very quite obvious is
not accurate and the results are not
acceptable and even clear the neighbors
and they have a very similar cantar
graphic retention this view can now
deserve each other and from here I
learned my license that sometimes for
now it seems like a you are saving money
but for the long-term run it could be
more expensive right
okay so here are more examples of why
you don't want to share internal
standards calibration curves without
their matching or corresponding Turner
standards they are quadratic and the
leading the to calibration curve the
first one the second one they are
speaking but you probably say Oh seems
like the last one looking okay linear
and they are quite tight yes the last
one also used for calculation for the QC
and unknowns turns out even the
calibration looks okay the results are
not accurate but I should say that this
is a specific or particular case that we
can not use the internet internal
standard to share but for most of the
like clinical analysis we always share
the internal standards so is
case-by-case right and next by looking
at to the calibration curves with their
corresponding internal standards it's
linear wide dynamic range and the two
calibration curves like Iliev really
tight I only have one thing to say it's
worth of the money right so so far I've
done all the series like experiments or
research so after I stablish the my
method and tested a method to show
accurate I started to do something for
fun now I bought some corn flour from
grocery store like I usually bought it
to make a cake or like a corn meal then
I did a test I saw this Camilla gram
still like I saw most of the mycotoxins
at a relatively high level I was totally
shocked and I know what Brandis I'm not
going to buy that anymore then I also
have another story to share
I actually had a picture here but like a
mentor to me all probably now using this
picture bus you can share the story my
colleague he is a huge fan of peanut
butter he usually has a huge jar often
about her in his office so one day I was
thinking oh maybe I should test his
subpoena by her to show him that how
much mycotoxins is eating every day that
came out and I touched her open about
her he was like oh okay but I don't want
to know the results I asked her why he
said uh hmm because he believes that
you're going to die off something
eventually
so he said I'll rather start no but okay
so after 20 minutes
I came back with this result there is
the only one mycotoxin detected and add
two relatively very low concentration so
it's like it's base and I broke my
promise I told him the result I told him
it stays the he was happy he said oh I
like my peanut butter again they also
shared it as results at the social media
so here this is a very interesting story
then you probably have questions for me
like okay since like so far you'll be
there like a successful like a results
with your method have you ever gone
through any like problematic matrix or
obstacles yes I do
I didn't show this in my like a
publication but I can share the
experience with you here it is the wheat
flour so this we flour give me problems
the one I was doing the Thompsons
pivoter they hurt my thumb because the
pressure you can feel it's really hard
to push the plunger down to the shell
bottom while then like even I could do
the few trician it also clogged my
columns many times that case I queued a
couple of my columns
I hope my manager won't hear this
because I didn't tell him so I feel like
it probably needs some like a special
filtration or something special like
some chunks specials back there I don't
know so I stopped to my working at this
at that point but when I was preparing
this presentation I was thinking maybe
in future if I come back to do this work
again I probably can try some code
extraction solvent and the freedom like
a lower temperature for a longer time
hopefully by doing so I can just have
you know like a remove some of
drunk I guess might be proteins or some
other like interference so hopefully my
experience can like help you or if you
are experienced things the same thing ah
please feel free to contact me give me
suggestions or we can talk about this
together
and here comes the conclusion so we
follow up to a pattern faster and
simpler LC method using the Raptor back
panel column and the total analysis time
is gone five and a half minutes so the
child's regulated mycotoxin genes for
different matrices were studied by two
different calibration methods I still
prefer like a cider device at of
dilution IC over other methods because
it's more accurate and easy although you
probably need to spend some money on
internet standards but still matrix
matching is another alternative if you
don't have to turn a standard available
and also this internal standard again is
a very important for cider
method so you better match the chemistry
of the target as much as possible
otherwise the you probably will have the
accurate results as I observed those of
zygoma method is to really a curative
bolos compounds which have the internal
standard and finally i would like to
give my special thanks to dr. chi John
from FDA for his greater support of this
work and thank you for listening I will
be happy to answer questions if you have
any thank you